hunter hunter stands never acknowledged
the flaws of the series fair enough
let's change that hello and welcome to
the new world review source for
everything anime and manga my name is
liam and what i mean to say is that i am
your source for everything primarily
hunter hunter because i like this series
i like i really like it i think it's a
monumental human achievement and there
is just no other story like it and there
probably never will be but with that
said it is still far from perfect like
very very far from perfect and as a
result a lot of controversial hunter
hunter opinions exist even from the
hardest and coreiest of fans so i
decided to ask for your controversial
hunt hunter opinions such as the
following the bungee gum joke is
overused which i don't even need to
reply to because username that i
honestly can't pronounce has me covered
the bungee gum joke has the properties
of both jokes and overuse and while i
may agree i have to admit that there is
something sort of comforting about
always seeing a bungee gum joke wherever
i go i love the idea that hunter hunter
is just such an enduring experience that
probably even centuries from now weird
high-tech cyborg space humans will be
making bungee gum comments to one
another on their way deep into uranus
speaking of dank crap holes the sponsor
of today's video
is not that but today's video is
sponsored by raid shadow legends the
game that exists and is by far the
biggest hit on the mobile platform but
one of their biggest highlights is
bosses in fact raid has an insane amount
of badass looking bosses such as the new
sylvania guardian of the spirit keep
although it's kind of sad because
sylvania has something that we would
recognize as a karapika type backstory
whereby she went out one day and came
back to find that her family had just
disappeared tragic and there is a ton
happening in raid this month in fact
there's a special event each and every
day as well as a brand new guardian ring
that allows you to use your champions in
all sorts of new and guardarific ways
and at the start of december raid is
releasing one of its biggest most
anticipated features ever take a look at
this so if you want to get a head
started raid all you have to do is hit
the link in the description or scan my
qr code and you'll get an epic hero
chenoru who is amazing in the doom tower
200k silver one xp boost one energy
refill and one ancient shard so that you
can summon an awesome champion as soon
as you get in game all rewards will be
waiting for you here these rewards will
be available in game for the next 30
days and only for new players so you
know what go and do the thing and good
luck shadow raiders but now back to some
controversial hunter hunter opinions
gone should never come back and this is
a much more detailed statement than that
but look i get you to some degree i'm
still kind of iffy about the fact that
gone even survived the chimera antarctic
however the conclusion i tend to land on
is that his survival gives a lot of
closure to kilauea and as the best boy i
can't really complain about that in
terms of gone coming back though i am
predictably on to four side here i think
that hunter hunter has evolved into a
story that is really difficult to tell
with a character like gone at the helm
who was very much the last remnant of
togashi's early shonen days that has now
spiraled into a dark political seinen
and i think that's a big part of why
gone had to become such a radically
different character during the chimeran
talk because his original persona just
doesn't quite fit in with what hunter
hunt became so i think just keep him on
whale island and let's finish this up
with karapika
if we ever finish this up that is i want
to see karapika become a villain he
would be absolutely terrifying his lust
for revenge is already scary just
imagine if he was a villain on top of it
and i want to say that we did kind of
see that during york new because you
know one villain killing another villain
does not make the original villain a not
villain also known as a hero i suppose
and that's definitely one of the very
possible parts for krapika to end up
going down at the moment he seems to
have kind of cast his humanity to the
side for the sake of recovering the
scarlet eyes but he's going to be torn
during the succession war because right
now instead of fighting for the hopeless
dead he's now fighting for the helpless
living in the form of prince wobile so
there are decisions to be made i
actually felt pity for neferpito when
they died ah this this is an interesting
one i tend to meet two different types
of hunt onto fans those that appreciate
pito and those that absolutely hate pito
mostly for the whole kite murder
situation but personally i did genuinely
feel pity for peto during the whole gone
fight if you can even call it a fight to
me it was definitely more of a
vicious murder it's weird though because
on the one hand it is very twistedly
satisfying to see this creature finally
facing some sort of consequences for the
sheer nightmare they've caused but on
the other hand pito grew a lot since the
kite killing pito matured almost in
tandem with meruem so it is quite sad to
see all of the newfound potential in
pito snuffed out by a child having a
tantrum but at the same time that is the
fate that pito brought upon themselves
as well it's bittersweet but if like
there was no sweet it's it's bitter and
slightly less bitter this show has flaws
but there's nothing actually terrible
about it i'm just trying to think if
there's anything that i really don't
like about hunter hunter there's an
awful lot that i used to dislike but
have since come around to appreciating
like the idea that togashi very rarely
has a satisfying end for rocks they
mostly just get to a point where they
stop suddenly and we immediately switch
focus to the new thing i used to hate
that because i like my stories with a
beginning a middle and an end and honda
hunter was more like a beginning middle
and then all of a sudden another
beginning but in retrospect that's one
of the things i really respect about
togashi when he got tired of writing
something he simply just flipped a
switch and turned it into something that
did interest him and if he didn't then
we'd probably receive a really flat and
not at all unique series as a result i
like the wordiness of the succession arc
in the manga i didn't find it to be a
big hindrance and it actually interested
me this may very well be the first truly
unpopular opinion i definitely found it
to be a bit of a hindrance when i was
going through it for the first time but
there's quite a few reasons for that to
start i came off the heels of the 2011
anime so switching to the manga was
always going to be a bit of a medium
shock and it happened to be during an
awkward this is a critical mass of words
so there is that and there's also the
fact that i started out by reading the
scans which are formatted absolutely
abysmally when it comes to dialogue the
official translation is well look at it
still undeniably wordy but the chunks of
text are structured in such a way that
it makes it look infinitely more
manageable and not just like you're
repeatedly smashing your head against a
brick wall of text during every page but
words are great so great in fact that i
would be happy if togashi got rid of all
of the images and just made a word only
manga which i think is called a book i
definitely wouldn't be complaining if
the succession waraq was finished in a
novel it would give togashi the space to
write about all of the complex drama and
nen technicalities just write as much as
you like without needing to worry about
all of the drawing and stuff that seems
to hold him back currently meanwhile we
also have the inverse opinion the
succession war arc is filled with just
novels of boring exposition and poor art
where none of the new characters being
interesting aside from the fourth prince
and it's hard to disagree because
honestly the succession war is that's
pretty much only as interesting as you
choose to make it there's a ton of
princes who i in no way cared about
until i started making youtube videos
about them and all of a sudden i started
to really take to them they each have
their own fascinating nuances family
dynamics and profound human ideas to
explore with the kakin empire in
particular each prince tends to
represent a different aspect of society
like how prince benjamin represents the
military ceradic the odds to bepper is
all about science tyson explores
religion and so on and so forth they all
have a really nice degree of substance
to them but admittedly you do have to
dig pretty deep to reach that substance
the only princes i have no feelings
regarding whatsoever are mamazer and
marion those two do feel a bit tacked on
to add numbers but look the rest are
fine genthru wasn't a bad villain his
power was cool and interesting
restrictions and he was pretty menacing
also his final fight with gone was
awesome so i actually wanted to make a
video about this but i am i'm kind of
afraid that nobody will watch a video
focused on genthro i've sort of come
around to him as well i still think that
he's probably the weakest hunter to
villain but to be fair the standards in
the series are pretty high he did have
interesting abilities for sure although
i feel like i would have appreciated him
more if he was just a weak not at all
competent combat dude guy who made his
way through this world with just the
insane ability of planting bombs i think
that might have been a much more
interesting exploration than just
turning him into a big bad shonen main
villain guy i guess the most annoying
thing about genthro is that we never got
to learn what makes him tick because his
abilities are terrifying they remind me
of the powers of the meteor city elder
actually who was able to create suicide
bombers but that was the result of a
very powerful need under great
restrictions so i want to know how
genthru landed on this solution for his
abilities and maybe the answer is just
he's insane and he likes he likes to do
the killing but if that is the case then
he's just not worth thinking about
because there's nothing to think about
evans arena was a bad intro for nen ah
maybe but what else could you do under
hunter was put in a very strange spot
early on because generally the power
system of a battle shonen is revealed in
the very first chapter for example one
piece showcases devil fruits naruto
shows off some chakra and black clover
makes some vaguely defined magic very
very obvious but nen was a bit more of
an afterthought and this is fairly
consistent with togashi i mean thinking
about his previous series you haka show
the spirit energy power system isn't
mentioned at all for like the first 20
chapters and then it goes on to become
pretty much the most important core
aspect of the series so with nen there
was never going to be a good
introduction though with how togashi
writes and particularly with the nature
of hunt hunter it was always going to be
a bit tricky however i will admit that
it probably would have helped if wing
had not deliberately mis-explained it
the first time we heard about it the
phantom troop is a cool group but it has
some very forgettable members and is
very unbalanced in terms of power yeah
so i did notice this when i did a poll
asking all of you to rank our various
phantom troopans i got a lot of comments
saying something along the lines of i
don't remember half of them and that's
fair enough because quite a few of them
have had limited or even no chance to
really make an impression because when
people say that hey they like the
phantom troupe chances are they mean
they like crolo and feitan if someone
says thinks and you know that hey
they've delved a bit deeper and if
someone says bernoullinov then you who
you found a true fan of culture netaro
really wasn't the strongest hunter alive
when he fought meruem
big words there very specific words as
well if you'd stated that netro wasn't
the strongest human alive that might be
one thing as i do think that beyond
netro implies exactly what his name is
however he is not a hunter so if we're
going with just hunters and that's
something we can actually quantify
because we know who the strongest
hunters are and that would be the
zodiacs many of whom are completely out
of contention compared to netero you
could make an argument for maybe jing
being a better nen user and therefore
also potentially stronger at the time
very maybe but the others including
paris and i just don't see it i mean
imagine a scenario where instead of
netro being sent to fight meruem the
association sends to say cluck and look
it just probably wouldn't result in the
same epic battle we all know and love so
i think that netaro may still have been
the strongest hunter but not the
strongest human election arc is number
one it introduces the best character in
the series paristan whilst also giving
the zoldix incredible added depth also
nanika is perfect i suppose i did ask
for controversial opinions but even so i
wasn't quite expecting that of every arc
in the series the election seems to be a
very consistent downer for most people
possibly because of sandwich syndrome i
mean how is it supposed to compare with
the huge story that came before it with
the chimera ants and how is the election
supposed to compare with the endless
promise of the dark continent
immediately after it it doesn't really
it just it occupies a very unfortunate
space there's definitely a lot to love
about the election arc but where it
starts to lose me is everything
involving terrordane this is an example
of a character and in fact a whole
faction that simply just does not need
to exist it's like togashi created him
thinking that he was going to be
important then realized that he had
nothing to do and so he had hisoka kill
him as much as i enjoy crolo and his
freaky spider friends the troop has long
overstayed their welcome in the series
every appearance since greed island has
felt ham-fisted to pad out the series
with chimera antarc being the worst
defender this is fascinating because i
definitely think it would usually be the
opposite i myself think that the troop
have been criminally underutilized and
i'm desperate for them to be in any way
relevant again which is another reason
why the succession war stuff is so
compelling because they are finally
taking the stage again for the first
proper time since york new city but if
anyone else out there agrees that the
phantom troop outstayed they're welcome
please do let me know in the comments
because it is a really fascinating
opinion almost as fascinating as this
next video because there's always more
to learn explore and experience with
this wonderful series so i look forward
to seeing you there